now I talked about Florida for a moment
I got to talk about something even more
disturbing down here in the state of
Florida
on Monday a Republican state legislator
here in Florida by the name of Webster
Barnaby
during a hearing on a transgender
bathroom bill that will make it a
criminal offense for a transgender
individual to use the bathroom of the
gender that they identify as
Mr Barnaby
went on
a bigoted disgusting tirade against
transgender people so we have the clip
of it here he is again this man is
Webster Barnaby he is a Republican state
representative here in Florida take a
look I'm looking at society today
and it's like I'm watching an X-Men
movie
with
people that when you watch the X-Men
movies
for Marvel Comics
it's like we have mutants
living among us on planet Earth
and you know
some people don't like that but that's a
fact we have people that live among us
today on planet Earth
that
are happy to display themselves
as if they were mutants from another
planet
this is the planet Earth
where God created men male and women
female
I'm a proud Christian Conservative
Republican
I'm not on the fence
not on the fence
there is so much darkness in our world
today
so much evil in our world today
and so many people who are afraid to
address the evil the dysphoria the
dysfunction
I'm not afraid to address the dysphoria
or the dysfunction the Lord rebuke you
Satan and all of your demons and all of
your imps who come and parade before us
that's right I called you demons and
imps who come and parade before us
and pretend that you are part of this
world Webster Barnaby Republican
representative here in the state of
Florida
the words that he used
like you're from another planet you're a
mutant you're a demon you're an imp all
of those words are meant to dehumanize
other people
he is dehumanizing taking away their
very personhood
of transgender individuals here in the
State of Florida now of course he issued
an apology oh he's sorry that he said it
no you're not you're absolutely not
sorry that you said it you're sorry that
there's backlash on it you meant every
word you said
you wouldn't have done that you wouldn't
have doubled down on it you wouldn't
have repeated yourself over and over if
you didn't mean it
and I got to bring up of course too as a
X-Men fan
his invocation of the X-Men there
actually proves that he he doesn't know
anything the whole point of X-Men is
that these individuals are are treated
differently
they are looked down upon by Society
because they are different because they
were born different
and they are the subject of of
prejudices they are the subject of laws
restricting
their very existence
all of that takes place in the X-Men
comics and this guy Webster Barnaby
doesn't have the wherewithal to
understand that he's the bad guy in The
X-Men comics
he's Reverend Striker
and he doesn't even
realize it
but that's who he is sorry it's not
Reverend Striker
but he hates these people because of who
they are
and he's pushing like every other
Republican in the state this bill to ban
transgender people from using public
restrooms of course again completely
ignoring the irony
of saying guess what we're going back to
the days of segregation
these certain people who look a certain
way can't use the same bathroom
have you thought about that folks have
you actually sat down and realized that
we're heading back into the days of
segregation we're not moving past it
we're not learning from our past
mistakes
and Mr Barnaby granted he was born and
raised in in England he only moved to
the United States in 1991 so even though
he was born in 1959 he did an experience
the segregation that was taking place
here in the United States at the time
I'm sure is a naturalized citizen he he
knows about it he had to have studied it
he is aware of what this country once
was and now he's part of the group
trying to take us back to that
for the record I've looked and looked
and looked I cannot find a single
instance
where a transgender person
has been accused of assaulting someone
in a public restroom
do you know why
because they're going in there to use
the bathroom right you're out and about
you're shopping hey I need to go relieve
myself you go in there you do your
business you wash your hands and you
leave
that that's it that's it and we're
saying that that is too much that is too
much of a privilege to extend to
transgender people they're just trying
to exist
they're not out there
breaking laws they're they're not out
there doing anything wrong they're not
coming after us they're not trying to
indoctrinate us they just want to live
and here in Florida and across the
country in red States we're saying no
Your Existence is offensive to me so I
want to oppress you
we have seen this before not just in
American history but in world history
and it never ends well for that group
that is being oppressed
but that oppression is alive and well
here in the State of Florida thanks to
people like Webster Barnaby
uh Barnaby Webster or Webster Barnaby
yeah I had it right anyway we got to
take another break I am fair and cousins
and for David packman you're watching
the David packman show we'll be right
back